you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest I
come and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game let's see what we get
best buy tests okay all kinds defense my
opponent okay for a second I thought
they had a connection issue I'm not
going to be playing the four pawns
attack
let's just develop a night
may even hold off on playing c4 now with
this blacks going to try to put some
pressure on my dark squares so I want
him around to control these two
I may want to play Bishop c4 yeah that's
let's give this a go
Bishop c4 and only after Knight b6 maybe
I returned here okay
so worth while giving a check now
not overthink it Bishop d3 does want to
try to reinforce this guy
don't a holistic successful I am with
doing this though
yeah
because I'm cleaning - D - there's gonna
be a capture and then Knight to d4 well
let's still give it a go I may have to
play f4 to maintain my pawn on e5 it's
very timely takes takes Knight d4 okay I
wasn't expecting that not a bad move of
course
going after my light-square bishop
so I guess black is going to get that
okay
I could have tried here forcing this and
then retreated that way the position is
a bit more locked up
already
take with the faun and now my opponents
gonna have an easy target against d3 do
not play this opening well we're gonna
try to make it work somehow I have just
a little bit of space because of this e5
pawn and that's the only thing I could
claim my opponent on the other hand has
the bishop pair
and I have a really big gap here on d5
it's not fun
get the rook in and maybe try to push
EEE six would drop the Bishop to g4 okay
maybe I could do what exactly
Bishop's somewhere all right how about
let's put the bishop here put pressure
on something
Roxy one I think I would like a dark
square bishop exchange let's put the
bishop here now if I go Queen III
there's night C for
already
what to do Bishop d2 just take the
knight in play queen e3
now
let's run it like this fish up to d2
still try to build up slowly these light
squares are incredibly weak but not too
much I could do about it at this point
drop that light square bishop he was the
better of my two bishops night before
Bishop back okay
let's put the bishop here I've control
of all four Center squares with my
Knights but it's tough to find a way to
improve in this position let's try first
b3 and maybe I could get away with Queen
d2 and poke around at the D or the h6
pawn
a little bit at an odd move rook to c7
not sure how much I'm really
accomplishing with forcing the king
there
how about this
put the knight maybe on g3
Bishop efore might be a bit of a
disruptive move and sure enough it is
played
I could still try to disrupt the bishop
post with Knight g3 I'm drifting my
pieces a little bit towards the Kings
side
think it is mandatory that I challenged
the bishop be taking with upon turn
reinforced here ID four-point and I have
to be careful of Bishop takes pawn Here
I am in some pin
fortunately amount of bishop ins maybe I
could push a little bit hmm let's just
get out of the line of fire for a moment
put pressure on f7
not too far behind on the clock on e6 I
trap the bishop where's he going
how about I go here now actually 9 on c5
could be pretty annoying Knight f3 and
maybe
hmm
I was not expecting that
hmm night on c5
hmm I think that Queen is too strong
there
I can't do
too much about that actually on Bishop
f5 maybe I have an e4 move I could prep
they're giving up the light square
bishop
I think I should take that as nice as I
like my night I think I need to get rid
of that guy
what are they thinking about let's get
my knight back into play Queen h5 Knight
g5 Queen h4 Knight g5 is a cheapo
maybe I should still do this I'm
pointing at some pieces Queen here would
be a big blunder
and how can i improve further
okay let's maybe come over towards the
queenside clean on c4 might be pretty
good
they play g5 and bring my night into
question we'll see a minute 19
so strong peace need to challenge her I
think
clean tanks I think I might take with
the pawn place e5 and then play against
the beep on let's inch my king a little
bit closer pairing for an endgame here
queenless
okay well that's starting to scare me so
let's just trade Queens
and maybe even trading one rook might
not be a bad idea
even though it ruins my structure but no
no I can't say that it really ruins my
structure so much because I get the D
file
I think this is a good move I'll
probably be challenged soon with Bishop
f8
exchange once now let's get one rook off
maybe a night on d3 is optimal
let's go for that rook a five rixy to
slowly fighting my way back
let's put a little bit of a clamp down
on these advances
I'd be able to rule them out all
together I think the night still belongs
here
I've continued to undermine this d5
point what's that move about feels like
a waste of time
let's just put the con here think I have
control over all the keep on brakes get
the King on a light square night here
may have may soon be winning material
forecast and I'll go passive
let's go here at King d3 there's Bishop
b6 I want to keep my knight around an
issue 4 B 4 a 4 B 5 now
roll over this position
and maybe I could do this
prepping night see five
even on the clock now
maybe before I jump into c5 now that I
have some control I get my king over
here a little bit
hmm did not expect that move
I guess they had some type of a push on
b5 there was c5
32 seconds from my opponents
let's try to come over here Bishop to e1
main mainly to rule that one out for a
b-1
King on d3 this bishop moves I get b6
this is the new seventh rank
it's pinpoints e6 and maybe I have a
break now
less than 15 seconds for my vomit I'd
end up in a pin now if I go here takes
Knight takes rook deep route to d8 maybe
next down prepping this just get my
knight activated and have a passed pawn
let's play here first I think this is
going to be a time when
let's shoot for this now
matters they're down on time I really
feel like I lucked out with this one big
time because the opening was just played
very poorly must be sad to to give up
the LightSquared Bishop like that
and you find a good set up so we'll have
a look at how I could better deploy my
pieces because that was a disaster
down the bishop hair and my phone I had
something to bite out and the only thing
that I was clinging to was a pawn on e5
and that remained for the whole game
okay well let me
bring up the analysis
okay here we go so let's see it's
considered the modern variation
g6 I know h3 is a move and fine with
doing that but right around here I guess
the idea to play Bishop c4 and then
Bishop back to d3 is just no good so I'm
getting nothing from here so there's
already an adjustment
I guess I have to insert c4 Knight b6
and then start bringing out my pieces
wants to even capture on d6 and there'll
be a couple ways that black can
recapture what is it suggesting taking
with the C pawn and then this will be
the strike that I have to be on the
lookout for okay so I guess the quick
point here is whoops quick point is to
insert c4 instead of challenging the
night with the bishop yeah c4
inconvenience the night and after a
capture then Knight c3 Bishop to e2 one
of these - yeah I have to take some
extra care over d4 so of these two
squares wouldn't want my bishop here to
mask my Queens view of d4 Bishop e2 let
me just play it out a handful of moves
here to get a feel for what the computer
is suggesting Knight c3 so pieces are
just falling on some natural squares now
pulling with the c-4 d4 structure
and suggest Bishop e6 but suppose nine
c6
just get on with castles and E 5 and
this is just an entirely different game
different pawn structure Bishop f6
yeah Bishop g5 f6 Bishop e3 f5 Wow
much different ballgame here and it's
also worth noting that it can be again a
completely different structure and reply
to this black can take like that and
it's much more balanced four versus four
on the Queen side and completely open to
e-file okay it's noted c4 is far better
so let's see how bad it really was
throughout it wants to go with b4 I did
point this out forcing this
the main thing here is that there is not
as much pressure anymore on e5 they're
still down the bishop hair but a little
bit of space but I really don't think
that's enough
okay I just gave him away after takes
takes it's not bad for me but it's not
better either I don't know
I would prefer to play black here so d5
square maybe even keying straight in on
the d5 square is a better option for
black instead of playing here because I
am going to push here anyhow its d4 and
a d4 so it's still equal I mean right
around this point it's very important I
take this square into account
you know because when this point comes
95 yeah I played Bishop d2 here and it
is best with just a couple seconds
thought at least now it's going to
Bishop III but the move that isn't a
good option is to take on d5 because I'm
really helping the Queen out and how do
I ever dislodge the Queen
I mean how I challenged it in the game I
think that was a pretty good idea I
didn't really see it
I didn't really appreciate what b3 was
doing exactly when I played it I was
just doing it to stop a piece from
landing on c4 but as it turns out it is
providing a pivot point for my queen in
the event of a capture I can recapture
and get back to controlling d5 with a
pawn right now this is a whole
so I played to d2 and now in the event
of Knight takes Knight I didn't get to
point this out I was gonna be taking up
the pawn so I could try to get the
center rolling I do after I'll have a
majority in the center two to one so I
can look forward to maybe something like
this whereas if I'm taking with the pond
then there's just I'm never getting rid
of the bishop and to think that the
bishop a light square Bishop on d5 in
this position is only worth three is
just way off he's more like a rook
so they
anything with those last few no so no
advantage for me
still somewhere even I'd be three just
keeping the night out of c4
so anything missed I went Queen d2 King
h7 it's calling from for some night
reposition
yeah I mean he isn't flying just yet so
I mean that's that's one of the things I
get with this space advantage well with
maintaining my d4 e5 structure whoops is
that the bishop is isn't playing just
yet it took him quite a while to get
activated in the scam
like their Knight H our Bishop e2 or
Bishop e4 Knight h2 I'd have to
challenge these light squares night g3
it's a fan of taking with upon and now
I'm starting to be a little bit better
these guys aren't playing really until
there's some type of break like would
really like to get in c5 here to help
out the major pieces and the bishop
guess it wasn't so bad I mean I still
wouldn't revisit the same line but I
thought I would have been I don't know
somewhere like I thought the evaluation
would be negative point six ish think a
little like down half a pond or
something like that I guess not
just kind of skimming here to see if
there's any mistakes any blunders Knight
c5 I'm starting to get a little bit
better here I just want to take that
Bishop out before it was too late
fearing he might back up you know I
never really even considered capturing
on force on probably not a good idea to
do that cuz this is a given is the only
thing I have it's just this tiny bit of
space I go for this capture now he's
brought to life you know Black has
helped with this kind of that kind of
capture
so I maintain my phone on e5 take out
the light square bishop and you know
guess it's close to equal now
anything missed yeah pretty even-steven
for this one and this ending game I
start to slowly pull ahead what was that
little hiccup no still just a tiny
advantage
once my knight is on D 3 that's a
probably the best square for my night
they should be 5 and now I guess I have
Nia Knight C 5 straight away is gonna
pick up a pond probably bullet mode for
both of us right around this stage I'm
holding some type of advantage close to
a pond
and yeah right around this point is the
last last thing I want to check out
because III should have done a better
job with getting a a pawn break in on
the queenside
King coming over oh here's here's
another you know earlier I was saying
the pawn on e5 made the bishop you know
he's not playing because of the pawn on
e5 what more is the Fon doing in this
position he's making life difficult for
the King to get closer to the center so
I have a better King position it's not
much but it's still something you can
see him coming up and being a far more
active piece let's say on c4 light
Square fourth ranked King versus the
second ranking
it's something and you know he could
always poke around here he's just a
moment away from targeting
g6 but right around this point yeah I I
wanted to play this move but they could
play c5 and I can only take once so I'm
in a pin I didn't want to do this have
my pawns split like that so I didn't get
to voice that during the game so that's
why I just captured on a5 but right here
maybe I should go straight in for b5 at
this point although what concerns me is
a capture recapture and then a push with
a5 having an outside passed pawn this
night this night cringes some a takes
and now a5
this is a tough endgame to assess stuff
to see how my rook gets activated yeah
this is a tough one to assess
not sure not away this one exactly
prefers white
yeah it's not crystal clear to me that's
for sure well as it played out captured
and in this final position it's still
even maybe once I get the pawn break in
it isn't now it doesn't even like the
pawn break and it's at this point my
opponent dropped on time what would have
been best right around here because it
is not a fan of d5 wants to improve the
King a little bit
huh what more to say well I won't be
revisiting this Bishop c4 back to d3
line I'll be going for c4 next time
around but you don't get to see the
Alekhine's defense so much interesting
opening for sure
I seem to have trouble with it not the
first time I've played it in a Simon
yeah didn't didn't get an advantage and
didn't get one here either but managed
to still come up with some tiny
advantage in the end game opponent
dropped on time in this final position
after d5
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you
[Music]